David Letterman is bringing down the
curtain on his final late show broadcast
on Wednesday it's the end of an
illustrious 33-year career for the talk
show host and comedian but let's talk
about Letterman's beginnings with a man
who signed him in 1993 Howard Stringer
was the CBS president who launched late
show on the network I interviewed him
earlier today in an exclusive for
Bloomberg TV and I began by asking him
if he worried whether Letterman's loyal
NBC audience would follow him to CBS I
just thought he would work really well
at CBS possibly even better I I never
had any doubts about the timing I
thought for one thing CBS had nothing we
had an empty slot and we filled it with
occasional movies and drama series but
we had nothing that could compete with
david letterman and so from our purposes
this is an opportunity not to be missed
and we never worried about anything any
of the details but Sir you gave David
Letterman 40 million dollars to move
from NBC to CVS some affiliates did
voice concerns about dropping those
reruns which were making them a lot of
money how did you convince them of the
economics of your decision and how long
was it before CBS earned a profit on its
Letterman investment I have no idea how
long before we end a profit but not not
very long it's is a long time ago and a
lot of waters flowed under the bridge
but the affiliates generally speaking
understood why we were chasing David
Letterman and how do we chased a
stranger they might have raised more
objections but I didn't really have any
difficulty I didn't have any affiliate
yelling at me a lot sir you were quoted
recently as saying that part of your
selling point to David Letterman was
CBS's rich history of news and
entertainment did that seal the deal
when you mentioned Merle when Lucy and
Jack Benny and EDD Sullivan I don't know
if it's sealed a deal I think it helped
because he's he's kind of a proud man
and Anna and he knew a lot about the
networks and Fox wasn't strong there and
let what there wasn't a Bloomberg so it
was so for him a CBS was an obvious
choice and we did have this long
catalog of iconic people to which in a
list to which he belonged I thought and
I when I said that to him in the in the
room in front of him on the panel I can
see him Brighton I think it was
convincing but I never said to him is
that the reason you came because once he
came I didn't really care what the
reasons were mr. stringer at any point
during the negotiations did you think
that it might fall through that that
Letterman might go back to NBC I I was
more worried about Rupert Murdoch
because Rupert as we subsequently found
out is very convincing I lost many
battles later with Rupert I didn't win
many and this was one that I knew he
would be a formidable adversary and I
didn't know what he had in his pocket
and I didn't know what else they can
offer him but i think i think david
letterman wanted to be honor on one of
these networks and yeah I I didn't
really think he was going to change his
mind sir what were your first
impressions of David Letterman when you
met him well I knew him so well I mean
to me he's a familiar figure he's very
smart very well educated very original
very imaginative humor I'd seen his
program a lot he reminded me as I've
said though I'm not sure he liked it
with David Frost and John Cleese's and
the smart people from the satire world
of the BBC and Beyond and so he to me
was very familiar and I'd even been to
Indianapolis a lot which is where it was
from but I just thought he had a kind of
sophisticated adult humor with a
satirical edge that belonged on CBS
because CBS was a mature smart company
did it really matter them that Jay Leno
consistently beat david letterman in the
ratings no no I I don't know I didn't I
leave this a different kind of humor and
therefore a different kind of audience
and I knew that it was a very
high-profile audience and a very good
audience for advertisers but I didn't
think about that I mean we were going
from 0 to 9 and a half out of 10 I was
I was very very happy and I liked the
show and in the end when you're running
programming you you don't bring
everything into the equation you ask
yourself is this what the network needs
and is this going to be good for the
network and our audience and I and I
always thought it was and he didn't
disappoint he's never disappointed sir
how would you assess the current
late-night network landscape has it
lessened in influence because of cable
TV or because of on-demand offerings
well everything is fragmented everything
has more competition you have so much
choice and of course time shifting means
you could watch David Letterman all over
the place and probably people are and
and so late nights change I think I
think the one single change that will be
missed with David is that David listens
and his interrelationship with the
guests is what makes him special because
he's so smart if you watch the people
who've been on the show this week
whether it's adam sandler or tom hanks
those are people that appreciate that
their conversation with David Letterman
is going to be funny but also
substantial have really required them to
be on their toes it because it's full of
wit and understanding and that's what
made him very special that's harder to
achieve you can sit in that chair and be
funny and entertain but your job in the
in the real sense of the world is to
bring out the guests I spent I once
spent a lunch with Johnny Carson just
the two of us it was the funniest lunch
I ever had but I said how come you know
do more of that he said I have guests in
front of me and I think David Letterman
understood that sir we have about 20
seconds left I have to ask if mr.
Letterman is flipping passed on his TV
and he catches you in this interview on
Bloomberg you have anything to say to
him as he retires well I I will miss him
I will wish him all the best it's been a
privilege and an honor to be associated
with him it's one of the best things
that I was ever involved with and I
think the network has has got a great
got a great deal out of it and I think
he did go into that iconic lineup along
with all the great names of the
of CBS